oi boa noite gente acho que todos nós
temos nosso coração de ver a sentimentos
alegria paixão amor tristeza e dentre
sentimentos temos a solidariedade a
solidariedade nem sempre ela colocada em
prática por quê temos dúvida de como
fazer isso e hoje eu vou dizer para
vocês que eu acredito que a
solidariedade é um sentimento que para
quem pratica custa muito pouco mas para
quem recebe ele vale muito eu quando era
criança ia para o parque com a minha mãe
perto da minha casa e naquela ocasião eu
vi as crianças da rua e com padecia o
vê-los ali na pobreza na miséria aquilo
me doía muito coração mais velho fiquei
adulto e continuei tendo esse sentimento
e tinha o propósito de encontrar ao que
eu pudesse fazer para atenuar um pouco
essa dor
oi tábata gosto de 1994 eu conheci uma
mulher que me chamou muita atenção uma
reportagem na televisão chamava-se
flor-de-lis essa mulher levou para casa
dela uma porção de crianças e começou a
cuidar delas eram 37 naquela ocasião
além dos três filhos biológicos que ela
tinha e aquela mulher não esperava que
tem passar do tempo o juiz fosse a sua
procura porque a casa não tinha
documento as crianças não estavam
regularizados e ela se assustou quando
ela percebeu que ela ia perder as
crianças ela resolveu fugir foi dormir
uma outra comunidade parada de lucas
aonde um traficante emprestou a casa
para ela morar e ela estava ali muito
assustada assando uma grande dificuldade
e eu não sabia de nada mas continuava
depositando um dinheiro na conta dela ou
de semana
é um dia eu lembro jornal vejo a notícia
flor-de-lis está fugindo da polícia
desaparecida do jacarezinho levando mais
de 30 crianças tomei um susto danado e
parei de depositar o dinheiro ela me
ligou me procurou o que que aconteceu o
dinheiro não entrou mais esse é o único
dinheiro que eu tenho para comer falei
lógico você tá fugindo da polícia não
vou poder mais te ajudar e ela me disse
então eu tô fugindo sim porque eu quero
ficar com essas crianças que são os meus
filhos são a minhas família não vou
abandonar os maneira nenhuma e aquilo me
comoveu eu convidei ela então para ver o
meu escritório conversar comigo e nessa
conversa ela me contou o trabalho que
ela fazia ela conheceu essas crianças lá
na central do brasil uma estação
ferroviária onde uma jovem de 17 anos
que estava embriagada jogou a criança
filha recém-nascida numa lixeira e ela
foi lá resgatou a criança e levou a mãe
e a filha para casa a mãe voltou para
rua deixou a bebezinha com ela alguns
dias depois voltou a casa
e acompanhada das 37 crianças pedindo
pelo amor de deus para entrar porque um
grupo de extermínio tava dando tiro
neles lá na central do brasil e ela me
disse entraram na minha casa estão
comigo até hoje eu sou a mãe eu sou a
mãe flor e aquilo me tocou eu fiquei
muito sensibilizado falei fugindo da
polícia não posso te ajudar nós vamos
tentar então regularizar sua situação e
junto com os meus irmãos e meus amigos
conseguimos alugar uma casa para ela
conseguimos a plano de saúde conseguimos
botar as crianças na escola e o juiz deu
seis meses para gente fazer todos os
ajustes legais quando passou esse prazo
ele foi visitar a casa encontrou tudo
funcionando me deu os parabéns e disse
deixa de ser um perseguidor e passou seu
apoiador de vocês fiquei muito contente
porque afinal de contas eu não havia
parado de fazer nada e aquilo ali aquela
família tinha se transformado em uma
lareira tão significativa feliz que
ficamos procuramos outro lugar para
apoiar encontramos a fernanda que fazia
o trabalho com
a paralisia cerebral em petrópolis
crianças que também não tem família
mobilizamos os amigos para lá
conseguimos mudar a casa de local
conseguimos prover alimentos roupas
remédios e aquilo foi melhorando cada
vez mais até que 97 quando eu fui fazer
uma visita na casa uma das crianças me
chamou atenção era uma criança nova e
não tava lá até então ela tinha 56 anos
ela ria brincava corria foi um te
enviando essa menina não tem paralisia
cerebral com a história dela porque ela
tá aqui elas não é verdade essa menina
teve meningite pequenininha com o passar
do tempo ela agora recentemente foi
parar no médico e os médicos no hospital
quando examinaram virou pela sua
envenenada envenenamento é caso de
polícia tirar a guarda é da menina
mandaram para o ministério público para
fundação da infância e do adolescente e
aí hoje ela tá aqui veio para cá porque
a fundação não tinha outro local melhor
para ela fiquei com aquilo no coração
voltei para o rio procurei a flor e
convidei a flor para semana seguinte nos
visitaram
o e fomos até lá e eu chegar lá na casa
da criança vir o meu colo no colo da
flor já fez um carinho quando você parou
eu propus da flor que que você acha da
gente levar lá para o rio até a gente
encontra um lugar para ela e a frozen
esse tá me disse claro vamos levar assim
vai ser muito bom para ela voltamos a
menina no carro e naquela tarde voltei
para casa da flor de lis com a criança
assustados sem saber o que queria
acontecer com medo inclusive e ela não
poder ficar na casa mas não chegar na
casa tive uma grande revelação porque as
crianças abraçaram a ela que olhando
como sendo mais uma irmã sendo tão bem
recebida como elas foram dia e ali
naquele momento eu entendi que sem
querer mas já vimos constituídos três
forças da força da flordelis dos nossos
amigos e do lar santa catarina embora em
locais distantes pessoas distintas havia
em comum a solidariedade que nos unia e
que estava sendo capaz de transformar a
vida humana esposito já votamos e com
passar do tempo voltando para casa nós
entendemos que nós temos
o meu nosso instituto a nosso movimento
criar uma instituição na sintam
instituto da criança para olhar para as
crianças do la flor de lis do a santa
catarina mais adiante os anos passaram
começamos a vick para as crianças
estarem bem temos que olhar também para
as famílias criamos um programa de
educação espaço cidadão para falar de
cidadania planejamento familiar a
relação interpessoal alcoolismo e drogas
e outros temas que são relevantes para a
educação familiar mas adiante 2008 eu
dei um grande passo deixei a minha vida
como empresário e passei a me dedicar
integralmente ao instituto da criança
acesso a trabalhar diariamente para
desenvolver o instituto e nesse momento
nós fizemos um planejamento e nessa
nesse encontro entendemos qual era o
propósito do instituto naquela época
fortalecer os empreendedores sociais as
pessoas que estão à frente dos projetos
e foi assim até o ano de 2015 quando
ficou pronto o nosso livro dos 20 anos
ao fazer esse livro foi entregue para
mim o rascunho e lendo e relendo racha
e eu finalmente entendi que o propósito
do instituto sempre foi e eu acho que
tem que ser a inspirar o exercício da
solidariedade assim as pessoas colocar
em prática esse desejo e perceberem o
quanto elas podem fazer o quanto elas
podem vibrar quando elas encontram esse
caminho muito daqui ó tem como objetivo
transformar a solidariedade em ação a
organização funciona como uma via de
aproximação entre pessoas físicas e
jurídicas que tem condições e vontade de
investir no social mas não sabem como
fazer esse investimento chegar a quem
realmente precisa ele conecta e articula
esses dois grupos assessorando empresas
canalizando os recursos financeiros
humanos materiais e conhecimentos
técnicos a fim de promover o
desenvolvimento social e
ah e assim se tu tirou uma empresa uma
empresa parecida com as empresas do
segundo setor só que com um objetivo de
promover o desenvolvimento social
através de gestão de projetos trouxemos
prostituto boas práticas do primeiro do
segundo setor com planejamento
estratégico como indicadores de
desempenho gestão de projetos be my
engenharia de processo auditoria
independente conselhos consultivo fiscal
checkpoint serve crm e uma série de
outros processos para que a gente possa
ser percebido pelas empresas como uma
solução ideal para que as empresas que
queiram estar ao nosso lado e 2011 houve
uma grande tragédia na região serrana
quando centenas de pessoas morreram e
dezenas ficaram sem famílias nós fomos
procurados por um amigo que o pai dele o
eduardo eugenio gouvêa vieira empresário
aqui do rio de janeiro que muito
sensibilizado com essa história
juntou-se com alguns amigos
olá amigos fosse possível construir
casas para os desabrigados quatro
famílias amigas doar um terreno para o
instituto da criança e o instituto
começou então a desenvolver esse projeto
fazendo a construção de 24 casas com 3
quartos para selecionar de famílias que
foram atingidas entregar ela essas casas
em maio de 2013 esse foi um momento
inesquecível o que foi possível resgatar
a vida digna dessas pessoas da ela dá
elas a condição de retornar para a
sociedade estava morando em casa de
amigos em casa de parentes todo mundo
ainda muito abalado e 24 famílias
ganharão nós repetimos terreno mas não
temos mais dinheiro aquela ocasião já
havia passado muito tempo da tragédia as
empresas já não doavam não conseguimos
descobrimos então que o governo de
estado tinha recebido da iniciativa
privada casas pré-moldadas que até então
não sabia onde fazer onde colocá-las
mostramos então nosso terreno fizemos
uma articulação entre o
o segundo e o terceiro setor ea se for
possível nós fazemos mais 50 casas no
nosso terreno e hoje temos lá 74
famílias vivendo de gra mente estou
muito importante para a gente porque nos
fez acreditar que sim era possível fazer
mais quanto mais nós unimos as pessoas
desse propósito maior era a força da
nossa rede e a capacidade de nós
devolvemos entregarmos para as pessoas
que precisam algo que seja útil na vida
delas
e hoje o instituto da criança é uma
solução que se apresenta como uma rede é
uma força e procura trazer para a
sociedade a cultura da solidariedade o
nosso grande desafio é potencializar o
processo o meio de ações conjuntas que
estimulem o público para atrair novas
adesões em escala exponencial queremos
fazer com que o instituto cresça em a
cada vez mais pessoas que acreditam na
transformação social ao nosso lado o
instituto da criança corresponde às
aspirações daqueles que procuram a sua
solução para atuar de forma efetiva a
favor do desenvolvimento social
oi amores 2015 eu estava em são paulo
quando eu conheci uma mulher apresentada
por um amigo e essa mulher me contou uma
história que eu guardo até hoje essa
mulher era secretária do presidente de
uma grande empresa e esse presidente era
também sócio dessa empresa e naquele ano
anterior ele havia vendido a empresa e
iria comprar uma nova empresa ocorre
todos os anos essa mulher secretária
fazia um evento de natal junto com seus
amigos e convidavam o presidente para
participar e colaborar todos os anos ele
contribuía colocava uma boa quantia mas
nunca ele podia ir porque ele era muito
ocupado no entanto aquele ano como ele
estava no período ali de mudança de
empresa ele tinha tempo e ela ficou
muito surpresa e feliz quando ele
apareceu na porta da casa naquela manhã
onde se livrar de uma festa do natal ela
então disse a ele presidente muito
bem-vindo fica aqui na porta receba as
e aí chegando e vai encaminhando na
medida que elas foram se aproximando e
assim ele fez passaram-se alguns minutos
o presidente entra na sala em que estava
secretária com os olhos arregalados
pouco agitado eu tenho que que os
presente tá tudo bem tá mas eu preciso
falar com você que que aconteceu eu
estava lá na porta quando chegou um
rapaz com seus filhos e me disse eu
preciso falar com papai noel eu falei
tudo bem o papai outras investindo pode
esperar um pouco né eu preciso falar
agora antes das outras pessoas eu vivo
aflição aquele rapaz resolveu levá-lo
até o papai noel que tava na sala ainda
terminando de trocar sua roupa ali se
preparando e o rapaz que quando chegou
foi logo se apresentando olá papai noel
oi eu me chamo pulando e eu tive um ano
em que eu cuidei da minha família eu fui
bom homem que eu fui bom marido eu fui
um bom pai eu fiz tudo que tinha que
fazer mas eu tô passando uma grande
dificuldade porque eu estou sem emprego
e eu queria diante do senhor e disse que
o ano que vem eu conseguisse um emprego
o papai noel incorporou o espírito do
natal e disse para ele olha meu filho eu
estou vendo que você realmente é um
homem bom e o natal e o tempo de
esperança de renovação e eu tenho
certeza que esse ano que vem você vai
encontrar o seu emprego
oi e o rapaz saiu ali feliz e eu tô aqui
para dizer que eu estou indo embora eu
vou embora porque eu vou procurar um
emprego para esse rapaz agora eu vou
ligar para os meus amigos eu vou dar um
jeito e assim ele fez saiu e conseguiu
um emprego para o rapaz e em seguida ao
abrir empresa já abriu essa empresa com
uma área de responsabilidade social e
essa moça secretária se tornou a gerente
responsável pela área e naquela época
ela me contou uma série de coisas que já
vinham fazendo uma história que mostra
gratidão mostra que num determinado
momento da vida o presidente teve um
reconhecimento da gratidão pela vida que
ele tem pelas oportunidades que a vida
deu a ele ele a consciência então de que
ele precisava por uma atitude diferente
já que ele tinha tido tantas vantagens
na vida e para ter coerência ele foi
acampar fazer uma ação eu a gratidão ela
só tem valor quando ela tem atitude
junto com ela nós temos que
a experiência com a nossa gratidão a
é mas vemos um mundo que as pessoas
nascem suas famílias com pai e mãe
normalmente essas pessoas nascem com
amor nasce com cuidados médicos planos
de saúde são bom para uma escola vão
para o curso aprenda e se forma o
conhecem pessoas fazem relacionamentos
crie uma rede e chega numa determinada
idade que entrou na vida produtiva e
começa então a trabalhar começa a ganhar
dinheiro até um bagulho alimentação até
uma casa para morar em uma vida digna
vivem bem do outro lado porém existe um
outro grupo social que ao contrário
nasce sem família sem pai sem mãe às
vezes não tem ninguém que fica no abrigo
fica na rua não tem umas não tem plano
de saúde não tem cuidados médicos não
tem estudo não tem curso não tem bons
relacionamentos e naturalmente que
acontece ele não passa para a vida
adulta de uma forma produtiva ele fica
vazio nessa hora nessa hora os que estão
ali em cima
a enxergar e eles é uma realidade
diferente precisão diante dias ter
consciência social aonde eles estão na
escala humana e nessa hora quando nós
temos a consciência é preciso que haja a
responsabilidade a responsabilidade de
devolver aquilo que a vida nos ofereceu
de uma forma efetiva criando soluções
criando situações que possam dar
oportunidade para rompimento daquela
barreira tão terrível daqueles que ficam
ansiando na expectativa de conseguir um
dia alcançar o conforto o bem-estar a
vida gira
o instituto criou um mecanismo para
ajudar as pessoas advance orarem o valor
da sua gratidão ora se a pessoa tem um
trabalho e ela tem 30 dias no mês cada
dia desse mês tem um valor esse trabalho
porque não pensar quanto vale o valor
total dividiu por 30 e cima desse valor
nesse orar um valor para doar aqui
trazemos r$3 ele tem morada também pode
fazer esse mesmo raciocínio vivendo 30
dias quanto vale o dia e assim apontar o
valor alimentação que o plano de saúde
transporte academia e vai saber qual é o
valor de doar pronto acabou dificuldade
e tem dúvida de quanto que é a conta
pode doar aqui já fica sabendo muitas
vezes as pessoas quando eu pedi a doação
e recebia me dizer o pedro não me
agradeça desculpa eu recebi a doação e
dizia as pessoas muito obrigado por sua
doação e as pessoas me disse pedro não
me agradeça eu que agradeço pela
oportunidade de doar eu então dizia eu
vi
é isso que eu comecei a entender que o
ato de doar é um ato ao contrário a
gente oferece a gente pensa que tá dando
mas nós estamos recebendo em uma só
quando a gente dá dinheiro é quando a
gente dá amor da atenção dá carinho da
olhar para o próximo nós recebemos a
percepção de que nós somos pessoas úteis
a servir a vida de uma outra pessoa aqui
outra pessoa possa viver bem também
assim eu aprendi que o ato de doar é um
ato inverso recebe se muito mais do que
se oferece muito obrigado a todos pela
atenção obrigado obrigado
e aí